[Música]
[Aplausos]
boa tarde
quero falar para vocês um pouco sobre
colocar a colaboração inovação aberta e
como essa estratégia pode ajudar cada um
de vocês a superar eventuais crises que
vocês tenham pessoais ou profissionais
como é que aconteceu a descoberta da
inovação aberta na minha vida foi uma
das transformações mais fantásticas
experiências que eu tive nos quase 20
anos de experiência profissional
o mais interessante é que não era algo
que eu estava buscando o que é inovação
aberta eu quero é preciso criar um
modelo de negócios de plataforma
as coisas aconteceram organicamente e
demorou muitos anos pra entender que o
que eu estava fazendo era inovação
aberta tema oficial para a inovação
aberta foi cunhado em 2003 e diz que a
inovação aberta acontece quando as
indústrias e organizações promovem
idéias processos e pesquisas abertos
para melhorar o desenvolvimento de seus
produtos prover melhores serviços para
seus clientes aumentar a eficiência e
reforçar o valor agregado
pois bem agora nós já sabemos o termo
mas o que me levou a quando nós
enfrentamos a maior crise da nossa
história e está preparada para superar
essa crise com esses conceitos
fui buscar a minha história voltamos pra
1980 o mundo ainda não é globalizado a
internet não faz parte do nosso dia a
dia
meus pais meus avós são físicos têm uma
ampla rede de colaboração viajam para
vários lugares do mundo para palestrar
aprender ensinar em congressos para nós
resta à imaginação com o fantástico deve
ser essa vida aonde eles chamam isso de
trabalho estão viajando para palestrar e
nós estamos aqui mas o tempo passa muito
rápido
chegamos no ano de 2000 e estão migrando
as ciências da computação no em ser em
são carlos chegou meu momento de seguir
a minha trajetória me mudo para são
paulo foi decidida a trabalhar com java
obrigado professor gilvan me apaixonei
assim foi amor à primeira vista começa a
trabalhar em conheço-os ou java ou
associação de usuários java
pra mim foi transformador conhecia ali
amigos e mentores até hoje bruno souza
um dos meus maiores mentores me ajuda em
uma série de decisões
tive a minha primeira experiência como
palestrante um ano de formada
decidi seguir a vida de empreendedor a
abrir me abrir a empresa junto com meu
amor meu amigo meu sócio vinícius encher
aquele aquela coceira de ser palestrante
internacional tava em mim desde 1985
quando eu via tudo aquilo acontecer
e foi nesse primeiro momento que eu
conseguir ser aprovada por uma palestra
internacional o maior evento de java do
planeta
imaginem só podia conhecer as pessoas
que criaram a linguagem eu podia
conhecer as pessoas que estavam fazendo
o futuro daquela linguagem e ver as
coisas em tempo real e eu estava ali no
meio deles como palestrante
foi uma experiência incrível
foi também onde eu conheci o java
community process o java community
process não comitê aberto onde os
principais empresas do mundo colaboram
na especificação mas concorrem na
implementação é uma plataforma de
inovação aberta embora assim como eu
comentei tenha demorado anos para
perceber que aquilo também tinha esse
nome
foi nesse espírito de trazer o que a
gente estava vendo e vivendo lá fora
aquela experiência aquela colaboração
aquela oportunidade que eu tinha tido de
me tornar palestrante um dos maiores
eventos do plano
eta que eu queria trazer para o brasil e
oferecer para todas as pessoas do nosso
ecossistema
foi nesse espírito de sucesso um momento
econômico extremamente favorável
a tecnologia java super bombando
literalmente e nós fizemos essa primeira
edição do tc 2006 e 2007
eu já tinha dois filhos neste momento e
nem tudo é um mar de rosas
eu me lembro eu estava me preparando
para uma palestra internacional super
feliz
aquela coisa vou pra europa arrumando
malas e me sentindo bem e encontrar
minha filha chorando e ela diz mãe
queria uma mãe normal cria uma mãe que
não viaja que fica aqui comigo isso não
é justo
nossa se desmonta porque é como mães
profissionais que trabalham a gente já é
carregado de uma culpa de estou sendo
bom o suficiente estou fazendo o
suficiente é esse o caminho
eu indo viajar abraço ela ainda mais
forte
chora um pouco junto com ela mas quando
fecho os olhos e me lembro daquele
momento em que eu era aquela garota que
estava em casa com inveja enorme dos
meus pais passando dois meses em orlando
mas no momento com a importação no
brasil fechada eles dois passando dois
meses em orlando e nem foram pra disney
e aquilo ao mesmo tempo me dá uma
confiança enorme de que aquele
sofrimento é temporário e aquilo tudo
vai servir de inspiração eu dou um
abraço forte nela e digo
maria fica tranquila eu tenho certeza
que você vai ser a próxima a viajar para
aprender ensinar e dar cada passo para
que este mundo seja melhor mas nem só de
problemas familiares de uma mulher e um
homem
a crise financeira em 2010 que a gente
não tinha percebido ela chegar porque
ela veio devagarzinho na no ecossistema
de tecnologia chegou forte
aqui tinha aquele sonho de empreendedora
está negociando com o banco um
empréstimo de giro agora mais agora mais
não sei como é que vai ser a folha e
olhava aquele evento estava totalmente
apaixonada é uma injeção de inspiração
de alegria de ego de um monte de coisas
que envolvem um evento e de forma
nenhuma eu queria interromper mas
conversando com vinícius no marido meu
sócio
a gente não conseguia ver uma forma de
viabilizar se a gente continuasse aquele
investimento iremos afundar ainda mais
tínhamos bons profissionais como é que a
gente não enxergava juntos alguns dos
melhores profissionais do brasil estavam
trabalhando dentro da nossa empresa ea
gente não conseguia fazer dar certo mas
com experiência de grupos de usuário
conseguia perceber que os grupos de
usuários eles tinham os mesmos problemas
eles também não conseguiam fazer um
evento fica rentável eles também tinham
problemas operacionais
eles tinham os mesmos problemas que nós
quando estou ali na minha sala olhando
placa prêmio adesivo é de notebook eu
falo poxa vida mas por que que eu vou
resolver esse problema sozinha
liguei para algumas pessoas e chamei
essas pessoas para uma reunião e tinha
uma música que ecoava na minha cabeça
todos juntos somos fortes somos flash
somos acutus nós no mesmo barco não há
nada pra temer a música tinha ouvido
centenas de vezes na minha infância eu
tinha compartilhado ela dezenas de vezes
com os meus filhos também
a resposta estava nela a resposta era
colaboração
chamei vários líderes de comunidades
naquele momento a gente batia muito
tinha ali pessoas de java python todo
mundo competindo
a minha proposta era que a gente parasse
de competir ea gente começasse a
colaborar juntos nós faremos um evento
enorme
perguntei logo cada um de vocês consegue
fazer um evento para 100 pessoas
todos disseram que sim e juntos nós
fizemos a primeira edição sustentável do
the developer's conference em 2010 para
mais de mil pessoas
foi um muito estoque era uma coisa que
as pessoas não estavam acostumadas
pessoas tão diferentes no mesmo ambiente
cooperando havíamos criado ali uma
plataforma de inovação aberta uma
plataforma complexa com patrocinadores
coordenadores palestrantes empresas e
muitos interesses conflitantes e aí que
a escuta ea empatia entrou em jogo no
ambiente como esse é necessário
plataforma de inovação aberta a gente
não tem o foco somente no nosso cliente
a gente precisa estar atento a todo o
ecossistema mas mais bacana é que aquela
receita permitia que o evento
continuasse desde então relevante a cada
ano porque a inovação não vinha mais
apenas de mim
ela vinha do coletivo das pessoas de
fora que estão nas empresas devendo
aquilo no seu dia a dia eu perdi as
chaves do evento ele não é mais meu
nós não estamos mais fazendo o meu
evento é o nosso evento e o futuro está
sendo guiado por todo o ecossistema
nós aprendemos da pior forma possível
que a inovação fechada em uma empresa
pequena no momento de crise não combinam
a gente não consegue todo o poder para
inovar
internamente em algumas situações bom o
evento em 2004 2014 estava dez vezes
maior
ando de rabo de cavalo pra esconder uma
um ciclo de cinco centímetros
careca é resultado de uma cópia exata
que vem do stress 6 30 da manhã
fornecedor me liga e diz
e agora eu vou desmontar o seu evento
inteiro você tem que resolver isso agora
pra quem não ligo como resolvo tudo
estava nas minhas costas
era minha responsabilidade naquele dia
que se arrastou foi nada fácil eu
percebi que a gente tinha que ter o foco
no nosso core business
eu tinha que focar no que eu sabia fazer
que era conexão entre as pessoas e eu
precisava de parceiros vai ser os portos
que me ajudassem a conduzir todo o
restante do evento
então o foco no nosso core business com
bons parceiros e os parceiros entre o
próprio plataforma como alguém que eu
preciso me preocupar também plataformas
têm o conceito de networking fex uma
plataforma por exemplo como telefone
facebook ubs só tiver um participante de
nada funciona
a gente precisa que tenha o maior número
possível de pessoas para atrair novas
pessoas e assim continuar a gente já
estava engatado estava tudo funcionando
em relação a esses efeitos de rede
mas num mundo conectado a gente tem
outros problemas que nós tivemos em 2017
um grande problema nas redes sociais
eu sempre fui uma pessoa feminista
sempre gostei da diversidade e vi essa
importância até por ser uma minoria na
área de tecnologia
naquele ano começou uma grande crise
naquele momento depois de uma abertura
incrível eu estava sendo atacada nas
redes sociais em grupos pessoalmente e
aquilo me machucou muito
pela primeira vez vou sentir realmente a
vontade de desistir de falar
não não é isso que eu quero o que eu tô
fazendo de errado o que não está bom
porque eu mas naquele momento mais uma
vez eu percebi que eu não estava sozinho
um veículo com dez linhas quatro patas
30 dentes silva valente
dos valentes ainda vai te respeitar
todos juntos somos fortes somos flash
somos amputou todos nós no mesmo barco
não há nada pra temer
naquele dia foi foi terrível mas tava
comigo o bruno souza o júlio matos e uma
série de outras pessoas ea governança em
uma plataforma de inovação aberta é um
dos maiores desafios na plataforma a
gente abre as portas mas como é que a
gente faz essa governança como é que a
gente lida com os erros e com os
problemas que acontecem eu estava
sozinha julgar tudo e todos
é muita responsabilidade ética moral e
econômica comercial
foi quando percebi que a nossa
governança também tinha que ser
colaborativa também tinha ter cooperação
na nossa governança
a partir daí nós criamos uma série de
comitês comitês técnicos para que a
gente pudesse selecionar os
coordenadores comitê de ética
diversidade que foi usada a primeira vez
nesse dia os aos processos de abertura
que já existiam de call for papers e
qual for trilhas a governança
aproveitando todo o poder da
inteligência coletiva e das múltiplas
visões mas como você pode aplicar à
inovação aberta no seu dia a dia ou na
sua empresa
bom separei três itens aqui a primeira
coisa acho que foi muito importante pra
mim foi que eu estava participando
desses ambientes de inovação aberta
participar de pensões participar de
hackathons participar de processos
abertos entender essa discussão
2 se você está interessado no modelo de
negócio de plataforma e o seu negócio
talvez não seja uma plataforma ou você
não sabe ainda que ele pode ser ou é uma
plataforma quais são as plataformas que
estão perto de nós e que estão no seu
nicho de mercado
quando a gente olha uma plataforma a
gente precisa pensar no todo
empaticamente de porque aquelas pessoas
estão colaborando porque elas estão
participando como aquela ponte da
motivação esse é um exercício que a
gente faz de pensar em todo o
ecossistema o que cada um quer e precisa
mas o que adianta a gente saber o que as
pessoas querem que as pessoas precisam
né pra que a gente possa realmente
aumentar o valor gerado num ecossistema
a gente precisa ter relacionamento de
confiança relacionamentos não estou
falando de fazer negócio trocar cartão
eu tô falando de relacionamentos onde a
gente de fato tem confiança para expor o
que agente kay o que a gente precisa ea
gente tem empatia escuta para ouvir o
que os outros querem e os outros
precisam para que aí a gente possa
aumentar o tamanho do bolo e depois
garantir o nosso pedaço e não sair
desesperadamente qual é o meu pedaço do
bolo
a inovação aberta é um jogo contínuo que
é baseada no respeito na confiança e na
colaboração muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]